[SFX: waves]
I had this hotel room for a week. On
the sixth day I finished it.
On the seventh day I rested; and on the seventh day
I tried to write a letter to my secretary
to tell her how I wanted
this to be typed up
and I couldn't finish a sentence!
It was gone; the muse was gone.
I would start writing and all of a sudden
I'd say "Now what was I going to say?"
It was flowing for six days and then it stopped
and so I think it's an inspiration that
I can't just turn on and turn off, either
Well, I understand you've been considering
all kinds of numbers under the sun
and probably the greatest kind of numbers,
because it includes everything,
is the surreal numbers.
The name actually came to me in the middle of the night; I have no idea...
I have a vague recollection that I saw, at one point,
a French paper that talked about
'nombres sur ordinaux'
I don't pronounce it well, but sort of sur- ordinal numbers
I've never been able to track down that
paper and I don't know if I heard about it
before or after I thought of the name
"surreal" but you'll see that it's
a great name after you understand
what surreal numbers are.
John Conway invented the concept,
and his first description of it was
"All numbers great and small"
Not only big and small,
but *inside* and everything.
So people know what the real numbers are,
and I call them surreal because
there are infinitely many surreal numbers
between any two real numbers.
[off-camera] I thought the numbers between
all the other numbers already existed, so...?
-Yes, that's what almost everybody
thought except Conway
So I learned about it...
I happened to be visiting Calgary in
Canada at the same day that
John Conway was up there, and we had lunch together and he had recently discovered
this concept, which we're going
to describe. During our lunch
he wrote out on a napkin all the rules of...
a definition of surreal numbers.
I was enchanted by this idea. Of course I
had lots of other stuff to do, but I kept
the napkin--I took it home with me.
The basic idea: you have a new way to describe all numbers: you build up all
numbers starting from nothing, and
actually nothing is kind of the
representation of 0.
But then you can use 0 to describe
another number which turns out to be 1.
And you can use 0 and 1 to make two other numbers, one of which is 2 and
one of which is 1/2. And you can
continue creating more and more numbers.
It's something like the creation of
a universe. Here we're creating a
universe of numbers. But the numbers that you get are always... the denominator is
always 2 or 4 or 8 or 16 or something...
You don't get everything... you'll
never get 1/3 throughout the first
part of this process, but you keep on
creating numbers until you go to
infinity. Then a big bang occurs and all
of a sudden you get all the real numbers.
The next day after that then you create
infinity plus 1 and infinity minus 1
You also have 1 over infinity which is
a number that's bigger than 0
but it's less than any positive real
number. That's why I started calling them
surreal, because there's a number like
pi plus one over infinity
This is between pi and
every real number that's greater than pi
And also we keep on going and keep on creating,
so at some point we get
1/2 of infinity, and we get square root of infinity,
and we get infinity to the infinity.
All these numbers that we get
we can add, subtract, multiply, and divide them
So it goes way beyond any kind of
numbers that people ever conceived of before
[off-camera] These sound like tiny slivers that we're dropping into gaps that we didn't even know were there.
-We got the tiny slivers and we also have
the reciprocal, 1 over a tiny sliver,
which is a gigantic thing, larger than we've ever...
people ever thought of before. So
that's why Conway called them "All numbers
great and small"  One night in the
middle of the night I said, "Hey, I bet
why don't I call them surreal numbers?" But the
the main inspiration that I had was,
I said "Wait a minute,
this is so cool, I think maybe I ought to
write a book for high school students
that would teach them what surreal
numbers are." There was a need for a book
that shows how mathematical research is
done, and how you take some simple
laws and create gigantic universes
out of simple laws.
And the process of discovering is
something that's usually not
taught in schools.
You just are taught the facts,
but you don't get to see the thrill of
developing these facts. I woke my wife up.
We were on sabbatical
year in Norway and I...
Well maybe I didn't wake her up till the
morning, but anyway I had the idea in
the middle of night and I couldn't go to
sleep and I said "Wait a minute,
a book like this ought to be written."
I was already years behind on books
that I'd promise to write, and I'm still
not done writing... that was 50 years ago
But I told my wife, you know
Jill, I decided I have to write another
book, but it's only gonna take me a week.
She said, well you know that's actually
kind of a nice idea...
...time in your life when you can do
this, here we are in sabbatical and so we
worked it out that a few weeks later
I would rent a hotel room and
downtown Oslo and spend a week writing
this book. She would come visit
me a couple times that week, because we
always wondered what it would be like to
have an affair in a hotel room! So that
was the plan, and it actually worked out
so marvelously, it was probably the
greatest week of my life.
I started out every morning having a big
Norwegian breakfast.
My hotel was very near where Ibsen used
to live so I could get some of his
vibes at breakfast.
There were a group of 50 American
students and I could listen to what they
were saying, because I had decided to
write this book in dialogue
between two characters:
Alice and Bill. Might as well show you the book.
Here's the book and you can see Alice
and Bill here.
My wife did the illustrations.
[reading] How two ex-students turned on to pure mathematics
and found total happiness
If you look on the web you find out that
that there's a bimodal distribution of
reader comments:
there are those who are looking for
beautiful mathematics and those people
are rating it at five, and then there are
people who are looking for a novel and
and some cool sex scenes and things like
this, and they're reading in a zero and
they're saying it's the stupidest thing
I ever did
and "Why would anybody waste his time?"
So it's a kind of a litmus test
as to what you like
Oh by the way, A is Alice and B is
Bill, but there's one line here which
is said by Conway and I went and
visited John Conway a few months later to
try to make sure that I could quote him.
So in this particular part, he's...
Conway says "Rubbish. Wait until
you get to infinite sets."
Alice says "What was that? Did you hear something? It sounded like thunder." Bill says "I'm
afraid we'll be getting into the monsoon season pretty soon." [off-camera] Is that the only line
from Conway? or is he here multiple times?
- I believe it's the only line that Conway
has in here. In the book, he's the creator and he's not only J.H. Conway,
but he's J. H. W. H. Conway, which is an
allusion to the tetragrammaton, the
Hebrew name for God. And the characters
in the book discover two axioms on a
stone tablet and also some markings on
the stone tablet: a surreal number
consists of two parts and you indicate it
by brackets and a colon.  You have a bracket
on the left.  To the left of the
colon your put some number
and on the right, er...
some set of numbers and on the right you
put some set of numbers, and then you
create more numbers. So you start out
with this number which is 0
and if you put 0 on the left,
you get a number which called
1 and if you put 0 on the right you
get a number which is called minus 1.
And this stone that Alice and Bill find has
these markings on it, but they have to
decode what it means for
these markings to do. Even though I have
hardly any plot in this book
the fact that I do refer to nature
and have a little story going on, meant
that I was watching everything in the
world much more intensely.
Not only was I listening to what these
students said at breakfast but I'm also
seeing the colors..., the leaves
on the trees... everything outside
There was more, too, because every
morning I was actually trying to create
the theory myself.
Conway had told me the thing
and I saved the napkin on which he
wrote it down, but I lost it,
somehow, in the next month, so
I had to try to remember it and
then I had to try to remember how did he
prove all these marvelous things that he
had told me about during the lunch? And I
purposely didn't plan that in advance,
but every day I would work on it and
then the mistakes that I would make,
the characters in my story would make
those mistakes. But then
eventually, you know, I got further
and further and was able to
develop the theory.
[off-camera] Had Conway not published it himself and he just...?
-No, he had the report: "All numbers great and small" was his report.
Then he was writing this book
on numbers and games that came out a few years later.
But at that point it was
brand new
[off-camera] If you are so much pleasure from this
form of writing, why don't you do it more often?
-Oh no, it's too scary.
It's not sustainable! [laughing]
I think you...  These are moments that
come once in a lifetime. But I
think also there was... it wasn't
just me, there was something... the ideas
were coming to me as if they were being
dictated, by some muse. The last thing
at night, I'd turn out the light
the next several sentences would flow
into my head. I couldn't sleep, so I'd turn
on the light,
I would write down those sentences,
but they were coming so fast, I only
had time to write the first letter of
every word, so I jotted that down,
turn out the light, go to sleep. The next morning
I can figure out what I was going to say
and continue. But if I had been doing
that all my life, I think I'd be dead
long ago!  So the characters discovered
this rock and it's covered with
Hebrew writing
that explains two rules, and
everything flows from two rules:
The first rule is: every number
corresponds to two sets of previously
created numbers
and furthermore, there's a left set
and a right set
Nothing on the left is greater than or
equal to anything on the right
That's the first rule. This makes a new
number. The second rule
describes what does it mean to be greater
than or equal?
So this is the number that we call 0,
there's nothing on the left and nothing
on the right.
Here we put 0 on the left and nothing on
the right, and this is a number that we now
call 1, but on the stone that Alice and Bill discover,
it was indicated by a
vertical line. And if we put 0 on
the right and nothing on the left
then we get something that on the stone
was indicated a by horizontal line. Now this
sort of Day Zero is when we got the
number 0. The next day we got the number
1, we'll call it Day One.
On Day Two,
now we can have a set of numbers, so we
can put 0 and 1 on the left and nothing
on the right, for example. And this is
actually... turns out to be 2.
Or we could put 0 on the left and 1 on
the right
this is the number that turns out...
is going to be 1/2. But now,
there was a classical definition of real
numbers by Dedekind called
Dedekind cuts: you have a set of
rational numbers on the left and a set
of rational numbers on the right. That
defines a cut between the two and that
gives real numbers.
So Conway's genius was that...
keep on going and allowing, besides
rational numbers, to allow any set of
surreal numbers. After i get to a
point where
0 and 1... (let me put a comma here)
And a 1 and 2, let's call it,
and you get all of these here,
but nothing on the right, this is
infinity. Then we find out what's
infinity plus 1? And that turns
out... actually got an infinity here, ...
These rules might have been invented
before Dedekind's rules and that everybody
for 100 years had learned about this in
school, and we'd considered that
this is the way numbers are. Then
physicists would have said that this
is actually part of the real universe,
that these numbers aren't strange but that
that these are basic. And people
probably would have discovered the real
numbers as a special subset of
the surreal numbers. There's no reason for
us to think that the universe obeys the
laws of real numbers.
People used to think that the real
world had Euclidean geometry, but now
people know that space bends.
The patterns that are revealed here are as
mind-boggling as anything in mathematics
and are far from being explored. Every year
more and more converts come along
and and we find people winning prizes
because they've advanced
the theory of surreal numbers.
...which is a subtle point...
So, I'd lost a napkin
but it turned out that the rule that
I gave in my first draft during those
six days was not his rule actually, but
it was subtly different.
Here, for example, is Chinese translation.
[Conway] ...don't like thinking of my impending
death, [pauses] and you know,
I haven't got all that many years left...
I don't quite know how many